foreign
[Music]
here in this video we will rank the 15
biggest mechas that are either related
to the G-Man or were seen in the many
Godzilla movies and Series so let's get
into it at number 15 we have the
vultures in the Godzilla anime the
vulture exosuits a highly Advanced
machines used by the human survivors to
combat Godzilla Earth and other monsters
they are equipped with various weapons
and equipment including missiles guns
and energy Shields they are piloted by a
single operator they are the smallest
Mecca on this list at four to five
meters or 13 to 16 feet in height
14 mega Godzilla from Ready Player one
in the movie adaptation of Ready Player
1 Mechagodzilla appears as a giant robot
spawned by Nolan Sorrento in the virtual
world of the Oasis it is depicted as a
formidable opponent that is capable of
causing massive destruction and is a
formidable threat to the players who
fight to win the Easter egg challenge it
is depicted to be 30 meters or 100 feet
in height 13. the showa Jet Jaguar it
first appeared in the 1972 movie
Godzilla vs megalon in the movie Jet
Jaguar is a robot created by a scientist
to help defend the world against
Monsters megalon in particular in the
film Jet Jaguar teams up with Godzilla
to defeat megalon and also Gigan
becoming one of the most beloved and
memorable characters in the Godzilla
franchise it stands 50 meters or 165
feet in height
number 12 the Mechagodzilla from the
show are movies it first appeared in the
1974 movie Mecca Godzilla was a giant
robot created by an alien race as a part
of their plan to conquer Earth it's
equipped with a wide range of weapons
and Technology including laser beams
missiles and an energy Shield despite
its abilities showa Mecca Godzilla is
eventually defeated by Godzilla himself
it was 50 meters of 165 feet tall
number 11 Mechagodzilla from the anime
movies in the Godzilla anime Trilogy
mechagodzel is not actually activated
and remains in a dormant State
throughout the entire trilogy but was
later evolved into the Mechagodzilla
City the aliens de Bilo Salado worked on
like a Godzilla in an effort to defeat
Godzilla but it is never actually
brought to life and youth nevertheless
the mecca not the city was 50 meters or
165 feet in height
number 10 kill you Kiryu is depicted as
a giant robot which is actually
Mechagodzilla and that is designed to
mimic Godzilla it is equipped with a
wide range of weapons including missiles
guns and a powerful energy weapon known
as the absolute zero Cannon despite its
advanced technology however Kiryu is
often depicted as struggling to keep up
with Godzilla's raw power it was 60
meters or almost 200 feet in height
number 9 the shower Gigan Gigan is
depicted as an alien cyborg monster that
is part organic and part mechanical with
a large saw blade attached to the
abdomen razor sharp claws and a menacing
appearance he is often depicted as being
one of the most powerful and dangerous
opponents of Godzilla and is capable of
battling Godzilla to a standstill it was
65 meters or 213 feet in height
number eight cyber Godzilla from the
cartoon cyber Godzilla is depicted as
being a cyborg or a robotic version of
the classic monster this version of
Godzilla typically retains the
appearance and abilities of the 1998
Zilla but it is equipped with advanced
technology and weapons that make it an
even more powerful and formidable enemy
cyber Godzilla stands at 70 meters or
230 feet in height
number 7 Jet Jaguar from singular point
this Mecca had a similar design and
color scheme to the earlier incarnations
and keeps the trademark grin of the
original concept being a Mecca created
by a small scale Constructor it somewhat
appears crude and steampunk in design
after the final protocol to make Jet
Jaguar Invincible I took effect Jet
Jaguar experienced a huge growth of up
to 90 meters or almost 300 feet
number six Robo Godzilla this version of
Mechagodzilla also called Robo Godzilla
was seen in the end credits of singular
point being under construction its frame
was built around the skeleton of an
early Godzilla which died and was hidden
underground in the 1950s Robo Godzilla
would be around the same size as
Godzilla Ultima since it would be built
around an earlier version of it so it's
100 meters or 328 feet tall
number 5 Mechagodzilla from the heisei
ERA this version from the heisei period
was created by the United Nations
Godzilla cartoon measure Center and
controlled by its military branch the
G4S using futurian technology scavenged
from the remains of the mecca King
Ghidorah Mechagodzilla here would then
later combine with the Garuda aircraft
to become Super MechaGodzilla standing
120 meters or 394 feet tall
number four Gigan from Final Wars this
version of Gigan from Final Wars is
depicted as a cyborg monster with a
chainsaw weapon in place of one of its
arms and a deadly visor in this movie
Gigan is one of several Monsters
Unleashed by an alien race known as the
zillions to conquer the Earth and it
battles Godzilla as part of the alien's
plans Gigan here is 120 meters a 394
feet in height number 3 moguera sin and
Godzilla vs Space Godzilla it was made
by the United Nations Godzilla cartoon
measure Center as a response to the
increasing threat posed by Godzilla and
other giant monsters moguera or
m-o-g-u-e-r-a is depicted as a highly
Advanced robot with multiple weapon
systems including missiles and a plasma
cutter it is also the heaviest Mecca on
this list but stands 120 meters or 394
feet in height number two the most
diverse Mechagodzilla Mechagodzilla here
is revealed to be a weapon created by
Apex cybernetics to defeat Godzilla and
other Titans and as portrayed as a
massive highly Advanced robot that is
capable of mimicking Godzilla's
movements and powers and even surpassing
them but his design was skeletal and
crude in form it was officially said to
be 122 meters but a more die-hard fans
like us it is clearly over 140 meters or
460 feet in height and number one the
biggest Mecha King Ghidorah this robot
Kaiju is depicted as an even more
powerful version of King Ghidorah with
cybernetic enhancements that include
weapons such as lasers and gravity beams
as well as the ability to generate
electrical discharges Mecha King
Ghidorah is the biggest Mecca on this
list seen in the 1991 film and it was
150 meters of 492 feet in height a bit
taller than the second spot entry but
both sharing the same Origins created on
a frame of a dead Ghidorah so those are
the 15 biggest mechas and robots from
Godzilla movies so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam
foreign
[Music]